[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum uh thanks for joining
me thanks for being here choosing this
podcast there's a lot of other podcasts
out there and if you're here for JK
Simmons I hope if you like the podcast
you know this was a little podcast we
talk about real stuff it's not celebrity
[ __ ] it's we get into mental health
Ryan we get we do it's a little bit of
celebrity [ __ ] just to start and
then you start with it but then you got
to get in you can't just jump in with
real serious [ __ ] you gotta dip your
toes in yeah and uh I hope you like the
show and if you do subscribe if you like
the interview if you like me chances are
I don't know what you're gonna like but
I hope you'll follow us at inside you
podcast on the uh Instagram and Facebook
at inside epon on the Twitter
and you could uh watch on YouTube
subscribe there write a review Apple
wherever you want it really helps the
podcast great guest today man this is
this is a legend legend
um what an actor sometimes you have
these guys on that you're like oh my
gosh she came in the podcast and that's
JK Simmons and uh boy did we talk about
everything he was really uh open open
about his life
um open about you know his brother comes
on later in the podcast Dave David
Simmons very brave brave soul who
attempted suicide twice and they came up
with this uh amazing organization the
ubu project and I was like what does it
stand for but it's actually you be you
you know what I mean and it's uh the
prevention of Youth suicide addiction
and bullying through social emotional
Performing Arts integration residencies
look there's a concert
coming up Saturday January 28th 7 30 pm
at Scottsdale Desert Stages Theater and
uh please head there or donate go to
ubuproject.org for more information also
look thank you for watching talkville uh
and supporting that podcast with me and
Tom Welling or re-watch Smallville
podcast but don't forget this little
podcast here
um patreon.com inside of you join
patreon support the podcast without my
patrons I couldn't do it there's all
sorts of prizes and things and uh you
know connections and and packages I send
to top tier patrons and support the
podcast if you like a little extra
something wouldn't hurt hopefully it
won't hurt patriot.com inside of you and
we need you also if you want to uh look
at the inside you online store you can
go there there's autograph Smallville
stuff scripts leximus scripts and lunch
boxes and inside of you merch and also
my band sunspin guys we just came out
with our new album have to promote it
sunspin.com you can go to merch see
these autographs zooms go streaming
follow us on the streaming platforms
just go to sunspin the new albums never
is what it is there's another album from
last year that we did really proud of it
and
there's no other way to promote it than
to promote to you guys um you know it's
not like I'm a big rock star here and I
can get millions of people to listen to
the album we're proud of it I hope you
listen to it I hope you enjoy it uh you
can get merch there or uh we're doing a
stage it show and that stage at show is
this weekend Saturday at 5 PM Pacific
Standard Time me and Rob and another
special guest we are going to sing songs
from the album and some covers and it's
a blast we'll call your names out as we
see them on the screen and go to
stageit.com type in sunspin for the five
o'clock show next Saturday or you can go
to sunspin.com and get tickets but I
really would appreciate your if you've
never listened to a show I think you're
gonna really enjoy it I'm very proud of
it and I believe
uh that's it I believe that's all why
don't we do it why don't we just jump
into one of the greats uh let's get
inside of JK Simmons it's my point of
view
listening to inside of you
youth Michael arose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
JK how are you
uh I am fine how are you I'm good you
know we met at the uh uh it was the the
benefit for the Australia uh you know
the thing they had for the brush fires
like a couple years ago and we talked
and I told you my Paul giamatti's story
about how he walked in on me at a hotel
when I was with my girlfriend on the bed
and do you remember that
yeah Jimmy apparently he does that all
the time he just walks in on people
while they're yeah it's like a thing
with him
it was amazing because I remember he
walked in and I don't know why they gave
him a key to my room it was an accident
but he goes oh oh oh I'm oh oh wow wow
I'm sorry and he just he just left and
and the next day I saw him he was doing
an interview and we locked eyes he
looked at me goes oh my God oh my God
and he ran up to him he goes this is the
best story can I tell this story I'm
like yeah of course you could tell the
story it was it was pretty good but uh
listen I'm good friends with Jason
Reitman as I know you are
and uh Jason I said hey I'm interviewing
JK you want to say anything and he just
said
he texts me says I love JK I absolutely
love this man he clearly is the
connective tissue between all my movies
he stands for a kind of craft that
almost doesn't exist anymore a sheer
unparalleled level of talent matched
with a work ethic you cannot find it
almost any other performer the ability
to be unrelentingly terrifying and in
the next moment completely tender one of
the luckiest moments of my career was
meeting him on Thank You for Smoking
well I mean that's uh you know that's
Goose bumpy kind of Praise coming from
uh Jason and uh
you know that that meeting on um
on Thank You for Smoking almost did not
happen because
it mostly because I'm so clueless about
show business in general
um I mean I had read the script I was
going into audition for Jason back in
back in the auditioning days oh yes and
uh and um
had to schlep all the way out to Santa
Monica from my place in the hills and
the kids are in elementary school and
you know things are very uh busy at home
and
and I slept out there to the casting
director's office parked my car plug the
meter you know get the get the uh into
the office
and I'm waiting and as usual you know
you're waiting and you're waiting and
you're waiting and my parking meter is
almost expired and I'm thinking you know
what I mean maybe I just get in the car
and go back home because the kids are
about to get out of school I can go pick
them up you know
and I'm and I'm at the parking meter at
my car deciding whether I'm going to
plug the meter or just say screw this
audition you know it's just another
audition
and uh and this young guy comes up and
he goes oh JK JK while you're and I was
you know at that time in my life it was
still somewhat surprising when somebody
would encounter me on the street and
know my name
uh so great to meet you and blah blah
blah and I sort of reached out and shook
this guy's hand and it was clear to him
the way I stared at him I had no idea
who he was he goes I'm Jason I'm Jason
Reitman I'm so sorry I'm late and you
know come on in let's let's do this
thing and you know like semi-reluctantly
went yeah okay all right went in had a
little chat with Jason and uh the rest
obviously is history you actually
auditioned that day
yeah yeah I mean you know he he
confessed that he basically had me in
mind you know from very early on to play
BR and thank you for smoking and uh his
one concern I I think at the audition
was he said listen I I I'm a big fan of
yours I would love to work with you and
have you play this part you said my
concern is you're so well known for the
Spider-Man I think both the first two
Spider-Man movies were out by then maybe
all three and um he said and here you
are playing another sort of
you know blustery boss he said uh you
know how can we kind of avoid those
inevitable comparisons and I like a
smart-ass dumbass said uh
I don't know I mean I could not have a
flat top wig and smoke a cigar
and uh and he went yeah okay I guess
we'll be good I mean do you find it
because I find it when you audition for
something and you start this banter back
and forth and it's fun and you're like
talking it's almost hard to then get
into the audition because you're so I
mean how do you transition into let's do
the work here from hey how's it going
all right okay let's do this would you
rather just not say a damn word and just
just go into it well yeah and and of
course you know the first 30 years of my
career that's what happened I was Guy
number 97 being ushered into the room
and like here's your name and they find
the resume and they go ready go and you
do the thing so you didn't you know
because they didn't give a damn about
who you were right
um it it was an awkward transition to
that point where they they you know they
have to uh uh you know your agent has
said now he's done this and this and
this so you have to treat him with this
level of you know and uh and those those
first many many you know dozens or
hundreds of little lighthearted
conversations with directors were were
really the hardest acting there was
because you're just trying to act like
you're cool and relaxed and and you know
in fact you're just as nervous as you
were at those Cattle Calls on West 46th
Street you know where you stood in the
snow for four hours before the audition
in New York
um
it was quite the transition and now you
know to be to be in a position where you
know I'm I'm so fortunate to not need a
job
um you know those kinds of meetings are
are genuinely all about like
are we on the same page
obviously I wouldn't be here if I didn't
like the material you know
do we want to go about it in ways that
uh not not necessarily exactly the same
way but you know can we can we
collaborate on this effectively and and
not just get along but you know have a a
vision that uh that Provisions that that
merge or at least overlap do you still
get nervous first of all do you even
audition anymore I I would assume you
don't but do you still ever have to and
if you do do you still get nervous or
and first days on set when you first
deliver those first lines or is there
nerves or you just past that I don't I
don't audition anymore there there still
are those those meetings with directors
that uh
that sometimes now are are uh suggested
by me uh because I read something that's
interesting but I but I want to make
sure you know that we're on the same
page
um
yeah the nerves I mean that that first
day of school thing really never goes
away or never has for me
um
there's there's always that uh you know
I don't know if it's a
nerves uh uh so much as just you know I
guess little butterfly is a little a
little kind of uh you know excitement
about
um you know I'm shooting something right
now down in Atlanta
and working with people that I hadn't
worked with before and you know
especially when it's you know it's a big
movie star you haven't worked with
before
um you know you show up on set the first
day and there's always that uh you know
as there always will be I guess at least
at least for me that kind of uh um you
know
uh childlike naivete about um oh yeah
I've seen you in the movies you know
you're a big star I do that too yeah
yeah absolutely
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look
if you're thinking of giving you therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside inside
of you is brought to you by rocket money
boy is this interesting and so important
if your New Year's goals are to manage
your budget better and save you money
you need rocket money say goodbye to
last year's outdated disorganized
methods of managing your money and say
hello to Rocket money the better way
folks the better way to hack your
finances is in 2023 and Rocket money
formerly known as true bill is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place now
listen a lot of people don't know that
on your Apple phone you can go to
subscriptions and you see all these
subscriptions you have and you realize
oh my gosh I've been spending all this
money every month because I didn't
cancel this or that and we all do it and
you could be saving hundreds thousands
of dollars every year by just having
this simple app Rocket money
why wouldn't why wouldn't everybody want
this it just makes no sense like over 80
percent of people have subscriptions
they forget about like that streaming
service you bought I bought and I just
watched one show I do that I just did
that for show time I just did that for
2B or something uh you know or the free
trial that you never used and all of a
sudden you're getting billed because of
the free trial is over not anymore
rocket money will quickly and easily
identify your subscriptions for you so
you can stop paying for the ones you
don't want rocket money makes canceling
subscriptions as easy as a click of a
button simply find the subscription you
don't want and press cancel and Rocket
money will cancel it for you no more
long hold times with customer service or
tedious emailing back and forth we don't
have time for this folks my business
manager yes I have a business manager
sounds pretentious but like he texts me
or emailed me he says you know uh
I go what am I spending so much money on
every month I don't understand he goes
well I'll send you a list of the things
so it shows mortgage and it shows all
these things and then it starts listing
all these things that I go what what's
this what's this app what it would it
I'm paying and it was like 380 worth of
crap I couldn't get that money back
rocket money
rocket money stop throwing away your
money cancel unwanted subscriptions and
manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com inside that's
rocketmoney.com inside one more time
rocketmoney.com slash inside do this now
look we're gonna get into which is in my
opinion the most important part of this
uh podcast when your brother David
Simmons comes out and uh benefiting the
ubu project to prevent you suicide
addiction and bullying it's a second
annual light your corner of the world uh
with JK Simmons and David Simmons who is
the ubu founder and uh that's Saturday
January 28th at 7 30 in the Desert
Stages Theater in Scottsdale Arizona and
that we're going to get him to talk
about that because on this podcast we
it's not just celebrity talk I like to
open up about you know mental health and
what we deal with as human beings and I
think why people still listen to the
podcast is because they want to hear
stories and and realize that you know
even JK Simmons he's he's a human being
he he has dealt with rejection and
anxiety or maybe depression or whatever
it is mental health and obviously your
brother knows a lot about that as well
as you do so
um we'll get into that but you know I
look at your career and I'm just like
you know people don't look at the
struggles they don't they don't
they don't understand how hard it can be
some people you know I've worked with
people who they were an overnight
success that uh just immediately oh my
God and he's a star and I'm one of those
who've just kind of like and I'm not a
star but I'm you know I'm it's one of
those things where I did something that
was okay and then something that was
[ __ ] and something that was pretty good
and then [ __ ] then oh that was good then
it's kind of been like that it's
fluctuated but you've really gone
through it and and you look at your your
resume and I'm like over 200 films and
you you know you got Academy Award and a
British Academy Award all these things
um but you struggled and I know that
you've talked about this a lot but I
think it's it's interesting to hear
because how many times as a young actor
did you think
you know I'm going to do something else
I'll be a teacher I'll Follow My
Father's Footsteps I'll be a musical
director were there those thoughts a lot
or did they never occur to you well
there there would have been more of
those thoughts first of all I hesitate
to use with regard to myself to use the
word struggle because you know even in
those early days where where I was uh
you know not getting acting work or or
sporadically getting acting work um you
know I was okay I was just a single
idiot you know and all I needed was a
slice of pizza and a friend's couch uh
in Hell's Kitchen and and that's what I
had a lot of the time and I and I had
friends and I you know I had uh you know
uh you know the capability to go out and
wait tables I wasn't very good at it but
um you know I I was I was fine
um
you know to me a struggle is a you know
a single mom you know working two jobs
and trying to be there for her kids or
you know or or you know whatever a
soldier in a trench somewhere um uh
those are those are the the real
struggles um
having said that the the difficult you
know times that I had trying to get a
career going I think if I genuinely had
another truly viable
skill set that I could have gone to I I
might have done that you know when I was
here in New York in the early 80s
um not not finding acting jobs and and
one time in particular I remember not
even you know I was back in town after
having done a regional theater job in
somewhere Buffalo or Cleveland or
whatever it was and uh
not getting a job not getting a job uh
not even getting much in the way of
auditions and then I you know hit the
streets looking for jobs waiting tables
couldn't even get that I mean there was
it was like nobody was hiring you know
anywhere and I'm walking up and down
every street in uh in Hell's Kitchen
Theater District and uh complaining to
my friend Greg Edelman uh who's a you
know Broadway guy here in New York and
has done a lot of film and TV as well
and um
you know we're just he brought over the
six-pack and we're hanging out and he's
listening to me you know Hawaiian about
uh how tough things are and
the next morning
the phone rings wakes me up I go out to
you know look at the uh answering
machine and Greg left two twenty dollar
bills under my uh telephone which was I
mean that's that's a solid week of of
pizza at that time uh so uh it was it
was those kinds of little little acts of
kindness from friends that I uh that I
look back on fondly and that I remember
the most from from that time you know I
think we all have egos I think you have
to have some sort of ego to be in this
business to have this I'm good look at
me I want the attention we all have that
no matter some people will say no no I
just do if I don't care about everybody
else and I think it's kind of [ __ ]
but you know the ego thing was there at
an early age when you're in New York
struggling and doing all these things
was there ever a big party that was like
how do they not see how [ __ ] good I
am
yeah yeah I mean
I don't know if I would phrase it
exactly that way but you know I mean I
by the time I got to New York I had done
you know I started doing summer theater
in Montana when I was in college at the
Big Fork summer Playhouse in Bigfork
Montana everybody go there
um my brother and I both worked there
um and then I spent a few years in
Seattle uh after graduating with my
music degree not knowing what I was
going to do you know I still at that
point thought maybe I have it in me to
be an opera singer
um but I just kind of auditioned for for
whatever came along and I ended up
being able to do a pretty nice variety
of things I was doing straight plays and
musicals and playing the leading man and
playing a wacky character part and and
and really not being Typecast as
anything and then I get to New York and
I'm going to these Cattle Calls
for like a leading man role and
everybody in the in the line Looks like
Robert Redford and I'm just kind of this
guy who's just starting to admit that
he's losing his hair
and then I go to a you know a cattle
call for some character part and and
everybody in line Looks like Marty
Feldman and they're all you know
hilarious and and I'm like
where do I fit how do I find work and
and uh fortunately you know
I had a few casting directors in New
York in those early days Alan felderman
Jay Bender uh particularly those two
guys who
who saw me as a versatile guy and saw me
in in uh in different ways and then I
was able to do all through my regional
career and and you know I hope it's
continued into uh my film and television
career
as Jason Reitman alluded to you know to
to be able to uh to have opportunities
to uh show different aspects of uh of
myself
different characters different at
different uh aspects of the human
condition that we're all here trying to
sort of shed some light on and sometimes
with humor yeah did you did you uh have
a good childhood where your parents very
supportive of you loving unconditional
love proud of you I didn't really get
that so I always ask people this
question because I'm curious as to how
it was in their child and how they grew
up uh yeah well never ask a question you
don't know the answer to right it's not
what they tell them the lawyers and the
interrogators yeah yeah we did uh my
brother and sister and I absolutely did
our parents uh
were incredibly supportive of of
whatever we were in and of course we're
particularly delighted well not of
course because you don't know our
parents but uh my father was a music
teacher they met in the chorus of a
musical in college at Knox College in
Illinois
um
Galesburg Illinois
um Evansville Indiana I grew up in
Indiana Southern Indiana there you go
yeah well we were you know I was born in
Detroit
several years in Ohio so we're all we
got the whole Midwestern thing we do we
do
um but our parents obviously very uh
supportive of
of our uh forays into uh the Performing
Arts and we all uh well my brother and
sister both played instruments I I would
I never my hands didn't connect to my
brain very well uh uh in terms of that
but uh you know we were all singing and
and and sometimes uh performing in plays
and this and that and they were very
supportive of that or or whatever or
whatever Sports thing I was doing or uh
you know whatever academic thing or my
sister just retired as a professor at
the University of Washington
um she inherited that the the teacher
Gene from my father my brother inherited
all of the above you know the the
Performing Artist and the teaching
aspect
um and uh yeah so that's a long-winded
version of saying yes parents were
incredibly supportive and loving and uh
and understanding of uh you know what a
career uh any career but especially a
career in the Performing Arts that you
know
it's going to take it a while to to get
off the ground probably I remember my my
I went to uh Western Kentucky University
in Bowling Green Kentucky I think Dan
fogelberg's thing about it
um but I remember them coming to see me
in a play and they took me to Denny's
because you know we're a classy family
and we sat there and uh I said
I'm going to be an actor and my dad
looked at me and I never forget he goes
eat your steak
[Laughter]
never forget it that's what he said I
don't think anybody believed in me
to do something like that and I don't
blame them I don't blame people for
going look a small town I wasn't popular
I was the shortest kid in school I
didn't know who I was I was just out
there and um if anybody would if you
would ask them what I would have done
they never would have thought I would
have become a successful actor in
Hollywood was there something because
for me I've talked about it but I did a
play in high school and I remember the
popular kids in the hallway the next day
saying hey you were funny who never
talked to me and I said oh not being me
I've talked about this then that's the
way I'll do it and was there something
that you remember a moment of
validation or Applause that made you
feel like I'm doing something right well
there were hundreds really I mean I mean
you know along the way go going back to
you know
my classmates you know my my teammates
from the from the football team in
eighth grade laughing when Kyle Lafferty
and I played Tweedledum and Tweedledee
in Alice in Foodland
um and uh and then and then I think the
same year the next year I played I
played bottom in A Midsummer Night's
Dream uh in actually not a midsummer
night stream all the Tinker scenes from
A Midsummer Night's Dream pyramus and
Bisbee for those of you Shakespearean
Scholars out there
um and and just kind of it was it was a
great
uh coming together of of different
uh aspects of of society you know in in
my junior high in high school you know
in those days in the you know late 60s
early 70s it was like you know there
were the jocks there were the hippies
the Geeks there were the the brainiacs
the Geeks you know they were the theater
nerds you know there were these little
clicks and they really didn't overlap
you know you couldn't be a jock and a
hippie and and
and I was struggling with that because I
was feeling I was sort of pulled by by a
variety of of different little micro
societies there and that was one of the
few times where I felt like uh you know
not that I was consciously attempting to
do that but but those those little
groups kind of intermingled and and
there was a a commonality there that
would that was uh uncommon right I mean
it's just you know you you you're for
one of your first roles you did like all
my children right
like you I know you don't talk about
that a lot but like I always find these
soap operas people go oh it's a soap
opera but the amount of dialogue these
folks have to learn and oh it was
terrifying I I could I couldn't do it
when I say that I really I could not do
that I would I would explode how did you
what were your what was your preparation
like trying to do something like that
well I was very very nervous I think my
first time
on All My Children
I played a couple of different
characters on that a few years apart my
first time I played a Canadian mountie
and Erica Kane for those of you who are
familiar with Susan Lucci's character
for a thousand years on that show
was was stranded on cobbler's Island
somewhere in the great white North and I
was a Canadian Maori not like you know
uh
Nelson Eddie uh not wearing the the red
outfit but you know in the office and uh
and I did my first episode learn my
lines and and you know she had more
lines than I did so so it was just a
question of not screwing up and uh you
know hitting your mark and and just
trying to be there and trying not to
hyperventilate and you know all the
experience doing theater all those years
and having those opening night Jitters
uh helped I think prepare me for that
um
the writing of course is not exactly you
know Shakespeare or Arthur Miller but
um but I you know I felt like I I
pulled it off I acquitted myself okay I
didn't soil my pants I I I didn't you
know fall off my chair and and it was
fine and then then I was called back I
was living with my aunt local at the
time off and on between uh their house
in Westchester where my five cousins
grew up or you know couch surfing in
Hell's Kitchen and um and my my
recurring line in my three or four
episodes that I ended up doing was
we can't get out to cobbler's Island to
rescue Erica Kane because it's fogged in
so I must have said 13 different times
did you tell them about the fog
and and of course my brilliant actor
brain realized after I had done my first
episode when I went back to do my second
oh wait I'm Canadian eh
so I need to say did you tell him about
the fog
and smoke so this character that I was
playing between the first episode and
the second episode which were probably a
few episodes apart you know in the grand
scheme uh I'm guessing some of the Die
Hard All My Children fans kind of
wondered wait a minute is this guy it's
the same guy right why does he sound
like a completely different human
knowing you you probably did really a
lot of research with that uh with that
dialogue or whatever yeah yeah yeah of
course we didn't have computers at the
time so I was at the library reading
about the RCMP yeah what year did you do
a Few Good Men on Broadway
1990
that was uh technically my second
Broadway show the first one was a little
flop Musical and I joined the cast of A
Few Good Men they've been running for
several months and I uh I got hired to
be the new understudy for the colonel
and the doctor which is a character
who's not in the movie so people won't
know who that is now this is before the
movie right well before the movie it was
I mean Aaron Sorkin was just some kid
from Scarsdale who got lucky and had a
play on Broadway and you know I mean not
lucky happened to be a genius writer but
you know nobody knew who he was uh and
uh and you know aside from the the
couple of movie and TV actors that they
had headlining both the original and
then and then The Replacements when I
when I uh joined it was Brad Whitford in
the Tom Cruise role wow and uh you know
the the rest of the cast uh Ron Perlman
was playing the colonel that uh whom I
understudied the rest of the cast were
you know relatively unknown New York
theater guys you know I is this is this
true that Aaron Sorkin heard that you
were going up because you were the
understudy and that you were going on
to play Colonel Jessup and he raced to
the theater when he heard you were going
on
and he was just to this day he said he
was blown away by this powerful
performance and and is it one of your
favorite performances that you've done
in your career that you can recall it
absolutely is
um honestly if I had to choose
the one
moment that that uh that was the most
profound and meaningful to me uh uh as
an actor it was it was
those four or five uh performances that
I got to go on for Ron who was
incredibly generous and and and Brad and
and the whole rest of the cast who were
so welcoming and opening and wonderful
and then and then yeah the highlight of
that being that
that Aaron came uh to see the show and I
don't recall if it was my my first
performance I guess it probably was
um
and uh
and he uh uh that interaction is is is
one of the the
the most fulfilling
uh moments of of my career as an actor
because I I
his acknowledgment that I had fulfilled
what he put on the page was was uh you
know
all I've ever strived for as an actor
this message is sponsored by discover
did you know you could reduce the number
of unwanted calls and emails with online
privacy protection the latest Innovation
from discover discover will help
regularly remove your personal info like
your name and address from 10 popular
people search websites that could sell
your data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
all I want
this is how selfish I am and childlike
is I'm I'm first of all I'm upset that I
couldn't I didn't see that performance
because knowing you in movies like
Whiplash and and shows odds and all
these Great Performances you've done I I
can only imagine you saying you can't
handle the truth and God would I pay for
you to be that intense get back to that
moment from 32 years ago and just say
you can't handle the truth I I would die
to see that did you do you think when
you watched Jack Nicholson do it did you
think I was right up there with him
it was I I'll be 100 honest those of us
who did the play
saw the movie
as wonderful as it was uh and and we're
like
the play was better
um wow in in in in many ways and and uh
you know look I'm not gonna say you know
that's the beauty of a part of the
beauty of what we do I mean people like
to hand out trophies and awards for the
best actor and the best this and that
but you know the reality is it's about
his apples and oranges as as you can be
Jack Nicholson you know when I played
that part I was 35 years old that was
what the character was that Aaron wrote
in the play right right he was not a fat
cat who was uh you know sitting on his
throne I don't know how old Jack was
when he did it but he was you know the
character
because he was the guy playing it I mean
because he was the guy playing it he was
it was brilliant but it was a different
character too because he was an older
guy
the character has written is a guy who's
he's on his way to the White House you
know or he's at the very least going to
be Secretary of Defense right or you
know a senator I mean he he's he's the
guy who's who's on his way somewhere not
a guy who's you know who settled in to
to this is you know I'm the king of this
domain and that's it so that to me was
the fundamental difference uh between
between those characters
how do those versions of that character
right how do you um
you I look at you you have a great
childhood and your great husband and
father I assume I am not your children
but how do you
find that place and where do you go to
when you snap when you become that guy
in Whiplash when you become Jessup when
you become when that moment comes how do
you go into that dark place and did you
ever experience such darkness that that
helped you with that moment or those
moments you know I I honestly I think
however
you know
easy and and privileged and and and full
of love you know your childhood and and
your life is we all have difficulties we
all have disappointments we all have
things that you know break our hearts
or piss us off you know we all have
things uh that we're you know uh uh an
anger I think that we carry around to
some extent the the um the common thread
and people who shake their heads at this
but between those three characters that
you mentioned and and what is what is to
me so important as an actor almost
always
is that for for lieutenant colonel
Nathan Jessup and A Few Good Men uh for
Fletcher in Whiplash uh for Vern
Schillinger and Oz
those incredibly deeply angry powerful
men
with their powerful emotions it all
comes out of love
however Twisted that love may be you
know in Vern Schillinger's place it's
like boy I love me some white people
you know I mean I mean that's the way he
views his his philosophy his world view
you know yeah not not that I hate this
that I love that you know in internal
jessup's place so brilliantly
brilliantly written you know unit core
God country that's what he loves in that
order
and that's what motivates everything he
does including you know
the illegal you know uh dangerous you
know horrible immoral stuff and the
justification for it it's
um it's always you know uh Fletcher
loves
Jazz so much
and is seeking Perfection every second
of his Waking Life that when anybody or
anything gets in the way of that you
know his love for that
then they're gonna buy God here about it
have you ever really snapped like one of
these characters in real life have you
ever lost your mind uh I
a few times mostly when I'm in the car
by myself on the 101.
um but but uh a very few times at work
and not
not quite to that extent not you know
not throwing any of those you know on
set
that we unfortunately have seen on video
of whoever yeah
um but I I mean I've and it's usually
it's usually comes from a place of
either uh uh you know what I in the
moment see as some kind of Artistic
integrity that is being compromised or
or or just a a personal
um uh uh you know just just
meanness or unkindness coming from you
know somebody in power whether it's a
director or producer or whatever it may
be and and those those are the you know
the handful of times uh
uh that I that I you know have
have
raised my voice and and said things that
I that I I look back and and you know
wish that I maintained my composure a
little better fortunately as far as I
know there were there were no cameras
rolling uh during those times
um there there may be audio recordings
out there
um and you know I mean yeah yeah there
are times in you know in in real life
when I was when I was whatever you know
heartbroken or betrayed or or whatever
when I was uh
you know
lost control
um yeah fortunately there's there's uh
the person that I was born to be and the
person that my parents raised you know I
I never
I never lost it enough to uh to take it
out on somebody in a in a way that was
you know that
uh that you couldn't take back right you
know I was quickly I just think of my
father's voice when he snapped when his
when he was angry and that's where I can
Channel it because it was the most
terrifying thing I'd rather him do
anything but yell at me like it would go
from like you know he was just a big guy
and that's just like when he got mad
he'd be like you know it would go from
I'm not going to tell you again from
there too what did I you know just he
would get so enraged and I'd be like oh
oh and you know that's sort of how I
channel that whenever I have to flip out
um Whiplash quickly
um
I there's few roles not not many roles
that I've seen where I say
not that I I can't do it but how did how
did he do that how
like it seems almost impossible like the
role you played the the dialogue the
snappy you know the the turning on a
dime emotions changing boom boom boom it
was it's not just to me the best
performance of the year that you won the
Oscar but and I'm not kissing your ass
it's just a fact that I know a lot of
actors most actors would say it was one
of the best performances I've ever seen
in anything I've ever seen and I just I
mean what was your work ethic to prepare
this
well I I've been preparing for that my
whole life you know when I first met
Damien Jason reichman sent me the script
for the short and the feature film of
this thing called Whiplash by this kid
nobody had ever heard of I have uh uh by
this time I'm in that position where
we're like I'm not auditioning quote
unquote but we're gonna we're gonna go
meet right we're gonna have lunch I'm
gonna meet this Damien Giselle now first
of all I read this script
and it is you know
up there with you know A Few Good Men
Juno it's up there with the most
brilliant things I've I've ever read and
potentially had the opportunity to be a
part of including Shakespeare and
everything else I did over the years
so I want to do it and this is we're
having a meeting to to spend a three-day
weekend making a short film for which
everybody's gonna get paid 173 dollars
but it none of that matters because it's
sheer Brilliance you know and I and I
want to be a part of it
we we set up a meeting to at the old
Daily Grill which no longer exists we're
on the top floor yeah of course we're
gonna have lunch there and I have this
image of Damien chazelle
it's a it's a brilliant brilliant script
obviously written by somebody who has an
inside understanding of jazz music and
what it is jazz music a quintessential
American art form particularly African
American art form
and Ice I hear the name Damien chazelle
and I'm going to this meeting and I'm
looking for Antoine Fuqua right I'm
looking for some big tall impressive
black guy with a you know Beret or
something that's that's my impression of
who Damien chazelle must be having
ridden this you know
and and I'm I get to the Daily Grill
like right on time and I'm looking
around
and I don't see Antoine Fuqua and and
then this you know this
skinny little kid from Jersey you know
kind of raises his hand and God JK and I
go
oh
wow okay hi Damian Giselle how are you
we sit down you know we start doing the
mutual admiration thing and one of the
first things he says is I wanna
I want to take the onus off of you as
far as the technical aspects of this
character because I want you know I want
you as the actor okay if you you know
we'll have a technical advisor we'll
have a body double who can do the
conducting and the long shots you know
he said don't worry about those aspects
of it and I looked at him I'm sure a
little bit oddly and I said
dude I
I went to music school I I have a degree
in music I thought I was going to be
a composer and conductor oh my God and
my father was a choir conductor you know
his entire career I said
that that's you know and and he was like
you know there's there's some kuzmet
going on here that's amazing he also
wrote it uh with Miles Teller in mind he
didn't write it for me he just when when
Jason suggested me he he went oh that's
a great idea
um he wrote it with miles in mind not
knowing that Miles had been playing
drums and cheesy rock bands You Know
ever since he was in eighth grade so I
mean the combination of uh you know a
lifetime
of of preparedness that brought the
three of us together on on that project
was you know it really was one of those
just just meant to be were you tough to
work with on that particular role were
you were you method were you like I want
to be this guy I want everybody around
me to be intimidated or were you just
jovial and happy JK Simmons dude we were
we had so much fun on that shoot yeah I
mean you you you had to because we were
you know we shot that whole thing in
like 17 days so it was insane the budget
and and the and the compression of time
that that created unfortunately Damien's
Brilliance and and uh
you know everybody who came together on
that to make it work but I mean you know
we're shooting those those kind of crazy
stupid 15 16 hour days on that movie and
and Miles who as we now know you know is
an alpha right is playing that that you
know Meek character
um I'm playing the you know the
character that I played Damien is this
young filmmaker who who actually between
the short film and the feature the short
film which was with Johnny Simmons in in
the Miles Teller part by the way who was
brilliant in a in a very different way
than Miles was brilliant
um but but the three of us on the
feature uh uh you know
just
had a great time just were you know and
and and Damien gave us the freedom as
brilliant as the words were on the page
uh Damien gave us the freedom to just go
off you know and and improvise and and
and do our thing and uh and the
combination of the of the the Brilliance
and the structure that that he provided
but allowing for you know us the
self-expression that that we both wanted
to bring
um I mean it was it was magic in a
bottle and then in between takes
we would we just immediately dropped it
and Miles when miles would go into the
yeah you know I'm not really a [ __ ]
and we would you know it was a very
different oh my gosh different like fun
vibe on set well we started a little
late I'm gonna get your brother out here
and talk about really important [ __ ]
here in a minute but I just want to ask
a few more quick questions
um when you went up for your Oscar
speech
was there a part of you that was
thinking it's about effing time or was
this because you're so humble
everybody's so sweet and nice when they
get these speeches and your message of
the call your mom and call your mom call
your mom it was just it resonated but I
mean
were you kind of like did you feel it
I've always felt like I didn't belong
like I don't belong here I don't belong
in Hollywood did you did you feel ever
feel like I don't really belong here I
don't really belong with this or you
know what was your feelings when you
went up on stage so I I still feel like
I don't belong yeah um and I I mean I I
I didn't there was there was no you know
it's about time
that ever entered my mind and I've had a
complicated relationship
going back to Childhood with the whole
concept of awards for you know Artistic
Endeavors and uh you know that that's a
whole different podcast
um right but uh it was basically
everybody that I knew who who really
understands the ins and outs of of
awards season and all of that I mean
everybody said dude there's no way it's
not going to be you so there was and I
had won every trophy you know two
trophies a week in the in the two months
leading up to that so it was
you know it was it was like if they if
they say and the Oscar goes to and they
don't say my name I'm a schmuck you know
because because that's that's the
expectation right you know
um so it was uh uh you know it was
almost a release when when they did say
it and then and then as had been my want
that that whole award season you know I
I never wrote
quote unquote wrote a speech
I didn't know exactly what I was gonna
say all I knew was the theme
you know what I wanted to focus on which
which in that case was was you know
what's really important which is family
and yeah uh started out talking about my
my wife and and thanking her for for
everything that she is and
and there are kids who were in the in
the balcony and uh
and then their relationship you know her
being such an extraordinary mother which
led me to talk about uh you know my mom
our moms everybody's mom and dad and you
know that how important those all those
relationships are and it was really
you know maybe the most rewarding aspect
of my
career that was certainly the biggest
audience I was ever in front of you know
I mean you know a hundred times more
people saw the Oscars than saw whiplash
so you know I was reaching this broad
audience and and uh and the feedback
that I got from that I mean from from
comical to uh to like deeply moving to
life-altering interactions that people
had with their parents as a result of
some you know journeyman bald character
actor telling them to call their mom and
dad you know it was amazing would you do
another Spider-Man if Sam Ramey
approached you
absolutely did you love it would do
anything that Sam Ramey approached me
with you love working with him that way
I mean I mean
almost almost anything uh this I mean I
could talk to you for ages I mean you're
just like you're incredible you're so
open and and we're gonna get a little
more open now I'm gonna bring on your
brother howdy howdy how are you David
Simmons I am fabulous hello with even
less hair
who's older
uh depends on the day bro you're the big
bro
David was he a good big bro
he was an excellent big brother he my
favorite Big Brother story is he watched
me sleep through a fire in our shared
bedroom in Worthington Ohio
as he and our mutual father were beating
at it with like wet towels and things
and
smoke was clearing and they look over
and there I am oh my God
he was a sound sleeper yes look David
you're the executive director of the ubu
project
I mean you have an awesome musical
career you've been in 50 all 50 states
across the world honors graduate the
University of Montana School of Music
and other school of music with your
brother uh actor director teacher artist
I mean it goes on Mental Health Advocate
is the most important probably and
keynote speaker that I that I believe
especially for this podcast and for the
world listening I mean and by the way
you performed with REO Speedwagon that
was I mean I did I did that was cool
that was
there's a cool and even cooler thing is
my very dear friend uh walterson was
their Road manager at the time lots of
long stories as to how we met but I had
written and recorded a little demo of a
song he played it for them they show up
in the dressing room of a show I'm doing
I get a text David come meet us at the
stage door I walk there
not quite ready to go on stage and there
I meet my high school heroes in my
t-shirt and shorts hi heroes yes and
they have learned a song I wrote so we
played that yeah yeah so we played that
at a an after show Cabaret which usually
has 10 people there 100 people are there
and you know they're going nuts but you
know this [ __ ] it's a good song and uh
crowd's going nuts and I'm looking at
the guys and that you know there's my
own I said you want to do another one
and the bass player like a kid in a
candy store
can we do Mustang Sally
oh my God yes we can choose a key
somebody count to four yeah it was it
was an awesome experience what's your
favorite really quick REO Speedwagon
song the both of you uh for me riding a
storm out without question yeah I mean I
I I'm not gonna argue is it weird that
mines heard it from a friend who heard
it from a friend yeah ballad [ __ ]
I am you know me I swear to God that's
just another Stalker Song that's right
up with uh every step YouTube yeah you
know what's funny is I had Steve lucasr
on the podcast who's the obviously one
of the best guitarists in the world from
Toto absolutely and he said the same
thing JK I said oh I just love
um you know that song Some people live
their dreams he goes oh you're such a
[ __ ] you like these love ballads he
said the same thing but I do all right
on to important things all right um you
know
the ubu project is just it's it's
stunning and you know thank you David
you're you're you're a Survivor I mean
you you've hit rock bottom you know what
it's like you've been there so there's
no better person to sort of head this
Mission than you and I just think it's
wonderful why don't you just tell me a
little bit something about you know
about the project and what you're doing
well uh very quickly what and yes thank
you uh being a a suicide attempt
Survivor thriving Survivor as I refer to
myself
is a very powerful thing uh March 31st
2009 I thought the world didn't need me
anymore and God and a bunch of doctors
thought otherwise and you know seven and
a half weeks on the psych ward blah blah
blah fast forward to 2016 or 17. JK is
is helping me put together a new CD of
Music I've been writing and I'm driving
across the Phoenix Valley and I hear uh
on the radio in an interview with the
statistic that the leading cause of
death for youth ages 10 to 14 in the
state of Arizona it was suicide unreal
and I was I was galvanized I thought
okay I'm I am a musician I'm a
songwriter I'm a teacher I've done all
these amazing things and more important
I'm a Survivor I'm recovering alcoholic
I got bullied you know blah blah blah
what does this all look like together
and so I thought about it for a while
kept recording the album JK sang on it
and then JK and I and my friend Walt who
was the road manager of REO Speedwagon I
don't believe in coincidence but we all
happen to be in LA
uh when JK was filming counterpart and
so we're hanging out in his trailer and
we're talking about this thing and he
and Walt went well of course you need to
do this and you know what are we going
to call it we came up with this name and
that name and the the phrase ubu had
been a part of my professional life
before and I thought about and I said
what do you think ubu project they went
yeah
and so what I did was was based on a
Model that our mutual mother used to do
a lot she was the head of uh artists in
the schools for the Montana Arts Council
and she would send you know theater
companies or a poet or a jazz musician
you know all of these you know top tier
people who just got tired of the Rat
Race and wow paid vacation in Montana
you bet
and I created this one week residency
model where I go in on a Monday I talk
to the kids depending on the school I'm
working with
sometimes I tell a little bit of my
story about suicide survival and all
that stuff sometimes I don't it depends
on what the school wants to do and for a
week we have this ongoing conversation
about what hope and resilience and
self-compassion and empathy mean to the
kids I never Define it once for them and
at the end of the week the whole time
and this is all wrapped in the guise if
they think they're in a songwriting uh
Workshop which they are but it's a
parlor trade because they've chosen one
of those four words I call them Treasure
Chest words they've chosen one of those
four words as the main topic of their
song
and by Friday they've written a song
sometimes it's just a chorus in a verse
maybe a couple of verses and a bridge
are thrown in there but two of my
favorite stories are there was a bunch
of fifth graders remainder these kids
are 10 years old
they're writing a song about Hope and I
use uh this makes me sound a lot more
educated than I am I use Shakespeare's
sonnet structure as my songwriting
structure because it's easy
um you know four sentences you know four
lines in any verse 10 syllables per line
there's a rhyme scheme the kids have a
framework to hang their creativity and
so I say okay right we're talking about
Hope and this and that what's a good you
know opening sentence what's a what's
the opening line of our song that is
just going to make the audience you know
oh my God I need to hear more and this
one girl raised her hand and I could see
by her face she had lived a lot more in
10 years than I had in 60. and she said
I hope that I get over my depression
and I said okay I understand that I live
with you know depression you know uh
post-traumatic stress disorder anxiety I
work with a therapist all the time are
you seeing someone yes congratulate her
told her I was proud I said okay great
now is it your depression does it Define
you or is it just something you have to
deal with and she thought for a second
and she said no it doesn't Define me I
said good because your sentence is 11
syllables long and we need to get rid of
one syllable what's one syllable that we
can get rid of and she said let's get
rid of my let's do
and so again room full of 10 year olds
came up with and of course it's an 80s
power ballad because that's the style
they chose for yeah
and they came up with I hope that I get
over depression because it makes me not
love myself yet that is definitely my
conclusion that's why I need some time
to have a rest
10 year olds are teaching me about life
balance in the chorus they came up with
shine as sort of the
the go-to thing shine hope shines light
on on depression shine hope shines
giving me compassion shine hope takes
away my obsession and then I'm going
okay we need one more one more in this
little kid like Horshack and Welcome
Back Cotter back in the 70s oh Mr David
Mr David Mr David what and you know I
could see the words coming from his
brain the audist mouth he goes hope
shines light on depression like a
diamond
no I do wow 40 Years of writing songs
never once have I come up with a mic
drop like that I'm surprised just
happens to be on my new album that's
coming out in a couple of weeks I mean
it's amazing and you're pretty much
saying that music is Saving Lives
absolutely that you know so the ubu
project augments a school's existing
curriculum with songwriting music to
help students address difficult topics
um you know it's amazing because I've
always dealt with depression and anxiety
and I've hit lows I haven't hit as low
as obviously you have gone thank God but
I have those thoughts and then I said
Whoa stop it stop it but you know tell
me just a little bit about
were you depressed growing up when did
this sort of happen when did it hit you
when were you aware of it and JK when
were you aware that your brother was
struggling
um probably when I slept through a fire
in our bedroom
um
that's a great question I wasn't really
aware of it because you know as JK will
attest as our sister will too we had a
great childhood parents amazing
supportive beautiful
we figured out while I was on the psych
ward after my attempt in 2009 that there
was something that happened in my
childhood around age nine or ten
that my child brain couldn't deal with
about and yeah and it could you know it
can be anything as simple as you know a
kid said something mean in a cafeteria
to you know I got beat up by a family
member and it was neither of those two
things because I never talk about the
specifics but my brain you know the
incident happened here in my brain just
kept spiraling the rest of my life and
so in the hospital
they died they went through a variety of
diagnoses and they finally landed on
major depressive disorder recurrence and
I was already dealing with free-floating
anxiety and PTSD
and they figured out
um and JK remember my 50th birthday on
the psych ward super fun yeah oh my god
um and uh uh and our mutual sister who's
sort of the family historian among other
things had put together a year 50 here's
David Simmons here is your life
scrapbook because you know we had been
planning on celebrating my birthday not
on the psych ward but you know and but
while I was there and looking at that at
that uh at that scrapbook you know
pictures from you know birth to
almost death and they figured out that I
had been dealing with untreated major
depressive disorders since I was 10. and
it was just untreated untreated
therapist therapist never quite figuring
it out and then after my attempt and and
getting out of the hospital and the Arts
by the way saved my life literally I
mean my you know my brother was a huge
part of it because I remember
um they called my wife at the time uh
and said what can we do for him and she
said just talk to him and I remember one
guy I don't know if you remember this
Kim one specific phone call where he
called and it was an hour of him going
um
I uh well
uh how about them Tigers
keep this guy some synapses firing and
then a producer
uh
three months out of the psych ward hired
me to do a national tour it was a small
role and while I was on that tour he had
also hired me to play Theodore Roosevelt
in a one-person show
and so on that tour I memorized uh a
one-hour script
and
it was that process that got new
synapses firing and things like that so
you know I look back to something as
early as at my 50th birthday on the
psych ward JK bought me a guitar
and that was one of the tools I used as
I was recovering on on the ward yeah and
kept playing and I would do these tours
that weren't guitar tours you know they
were you know sort of traditional
musical comedy which is great but I was
I would always have a guitar with me
yeah you know and then you know like I
said
2017 or so
I was galvanized to I knew I had to do
something I had to take all my
experiences all my training everything
and focus it on something that to this
day I haven't found another organization
that does what we do it's a lot of great
organizations out there but yeah uh it
amazes me I think people don't think
about
uh not just themselves when they go
through this and it's all the horrors
that I'm going through but what weight
it puts on family so JK what was
were you shell-shocked was it something
that you had any inkling of like knowing
that he was suffering or dealing with
this stuff what was what were your
emotions like well we uh you're talking
about that 50th birthday in the psych
ward I mean that you know off and on
over the years and of course you look
back he's 10 I'm 14 you know and and and
we were a lot of the time that we were
growing up you know we were in very
different circles you know we almost
never went to the same school together
until we were uh because it took me
forever to graduate college until we
ended up as as college class uh not
classmates but together at University of
Montana
um so so you know I'm 14 years old I'm
this you know I'm adolescent consumed
with all the things that adolescents are
consumed with and my little brother is
just my little brother he's just this
little kid who's always been there and
you know sometimes he's a pain in the
ass and sometimes we're having fun
together but uh but he's you know he's
enough younger that that were in
completely different like social
spheres you know
um
it's easy to look back now and and see
you know
that he that he has often on been
troubled and that there have been times
when that's gotten the best of him as it
does almost all of us you know at one
time or another and and then you know
some of this some of the stuff he he
lived through as an adult some of the uh
the difficulties the heart breaks the uh
um the problems that again you know in
and of themselves uh are are
I don't want to say unremarkable but but
I mean you know we all go through [ __ ]
right and um and and your proclivity
your your your your your mental health
you know is affected uh to a different
degree depending on uh a variety of
things obviously
none of us even even during times of of
you know particularly sort of
tempestuous times when there was concern
about is David okay you know
it it never occurred to any of us how
not okay he was at that time
and uh and when you have a family you
know a a birth family that's as loving
and as close knit as as we were with our
parents and and our parents who were
also like the world's best grandparents
uh um you know David has a son I have
two kids our our sister has three kids
uh and now multiple grandkids um
you know for us all to be just
completely
gobsmacked by that and and you know
having already made plans
to go to Minnesota and and celebrate his
his 50th you know big milestone birthday
and then yeah finding ourselves there
with this with this
shell of a human being you know who was
uh uh you know I mean something that I
hadn't seen uh you know made me made me
understand and appreciate some of the
good work in Cuckoo's Nest more so
because because you know to look at your
brother's eyes
and and not see your brother
um was uh
uh difficult and and uh
and sobering and and uh I think as is
the case for a lot of people when when
someone you love is in
that level of of uh pain and difficulty
you know you uh we all tend to blame
ourselves to some extent you know how
did I not see that you know how you know
how how am I so self-consumed that uh
you know that I don't see the pain of
those around me and and you know coming
full circle
that's one of the things that he's
teaching now
uh to these kids who just think they're
having fun writing songs for a week you
know uh you know one of the tools he's
he's giving them is that not only that
that self-empathy
um but but you know the compassion I
mean we joke about it but it's but it's
an absolutely true phrase to say that
he's saving the world one kid at a time
and and every week that he's out there
doing that he's so you know that ripple
effect that butterfly effect is is
kicking in and uh and he's having effect
on the lives of people that he'll never
meet that's beautiful you know I uh
David a few minutes ago when you were
talking about how you block you have a
tendency as a child to block out those
really dark times somehow to protect
yourself I think that's what the body
does I had an experience where you know
I I was in a situation where it was it
was uncomfortable I was I was almost
molested to the point where it was it
was a dark scary story I won't get you
into that but I I escaped
and I was supposed to be at my
grandparents Bungalow Upstate like I was
a little boy and I was just like a few
Bungalows away and uh
I remember I had an hour and it would
only been like 35 minutes but I knew as
a little boy as an eight-year-old kid
Maybe
that I can't go into the Bungalow to my
grandparents right now and because they
can't see the way I am right now because
I was so shook somehow I knew and I had
to gather myself and I remember sitting
behind this tree for like 30 minutes to
compose myself and went in and from that
day I blocked that moment out
for 20 years and
um
I so I I know what it's like to be a
child who feels like they don't want to
be shamed or it's their fault and that's
why I didn't tell anybody and even
though nothing really happened still
devastated me and I and I and I didn't
and I think a lot of kids deal with not
only that you know bullying and
molestation whatever it is
um dysfunctional families and we block
out a lot of stuff and it resurfaces
when we get older and it's how we deal
with it so you know it's um to be able
to get kids at a young age to sort of be
in touch with their feelings is not an
easy task and it seems like through
music you're able to at least break
break the the surface or whatever and
tap into a little bit to give them some
comfort and kind of healing well and
that's sorry I'm butting in here but
that that's the Brilliance of what David
has uh uh has designated as the tool kit
you know he's giving he gives these kids
tools uh to and which again they think
is is about you know songwriting and it
is there have been some great songs that
have come out of it uh but you know he's
he's giving them the tools to to dig out
of you know whatever hole it is that
they're in and uh and and again having
that having that effect on on a number
of kids on a weekly basis didn't this
didn't this organization this Foundation
sort of start and and how many kids have
joined to isn't it like something
astounding like 7 000 kids now are part
of a program or something tell me if I'm
wrong right um it's uh yeah it's not
like a traditional arts program where I
work with all these Arts kids uh our
wheelhouse is you know Mrs
McGillicuddy's fourth grade classroom
and there may be a couple of artsy kids
in there but it's mostly creating common
ground in a safe space so kids with no
experience or lots of experience feel
safe and comfortable creating all stuff
we started in our hometown in Missoula
Montana in September of 2018 we're
coming up on our fifth year
we have in the classroom itself
one-on-one you know in the classroom
with kids
that specifically we're at about 5 000
but if you include all the virtual work
we did during the uh the pandemic
conferences uh and things like that
we're at about 15 to 20 000 people who
have experienced you know some call it a
tool kit I refer to it as a treasure
chest because it's something the kids
already have and I said you know it's
already there and you know I work with
kids in juvenile detention a lot of them
say I have no hope and I say yeah you do
you just don't know where it is and
we're gonna try and find it and very
quickly speaking of cool songs this is
also on my new album
um the kids I worked with in juvenile
detention wrote a tune called don't give
up on life about resilience and one of
the things I do all the Spanish I know I
have learned from my students and so if
I have a number of bilingual students
I'll say let's translate this or what do
you want to do and so they came up with
uh the chorus they came up with was and
I also learned a new style called which
is a kind of Mexican music and the the
chorus of their song was dirt years
don't give up on life Everything Will
Change don't give up on life everything
will change
anything can be the light if you push
through and fight don't give up on life
recording I do my best you know that is
Carlos Santana but yeah yeah these are a
bunch of kids and I got a note from a
kid I'm getting goosebumps you Can't
fake Goosebumps I got a note from
achillion juvie uh his first name is
Eddie I can say that and it was instead
of a you know one of the notes we got
from a Junior High kid was lately I've
been feeling like thinking of killing
myself but you teached me about hope
but this kid wrote this long letter of
dear date Dave because we're Pals now
dear Dave I've been thinking a lot about
what you talked about and I get it now I
understand hope and my plan is 10 years
from now when I'm out of here I'm going
to prove them wrong I'm going to prove
the people wrong who told me I'd end up
in prison like my birth parents I'm
going to show up at their door with my
wife and my kids and my job and say I'm
proving you wrong I made something of
myself and I'm like
good Lord you know that's my Christmas
bonus this is an outlet this is another
absolutely that I don't think a lot of
people are aware of and I'm so happy and
glad and you know just thankful that you
came up with this idea and that you're
working to help these children around
the world with this because I think it's
something that's ignored I didn't know
these statistics I didn't know 10 years
old to 14 suicidal how could it be that
it's just overwhelming so first lastly
to let you guys go and I know you got to
go but the benefit is the ubu project to
prevent you suicide addiction and
bullying it's the second annual light
your corner of the world with JK Simmons
and David Simmons
um the date is Saturday January 28th
it's coming up very soon so you you
really need to go into 7 30 at the
Desert Stages Theater in Scottsville uh
at the Fashion Square you can go to
www.desertstages.org it's spelled
d-e-s-e-r-t because I would have spelled
it dessert stages.org
480-483-1664
um this is a beautiful thing we're going
to post this we're going to get
awareness out there
um I love the both of you I I don't even
know you but I feel like you know you
guys are just remarkable human beings
thanks for your stories thanks for uh
just being you and um helping uh helping
people you know that's it let me just
wedge in there that anybody that can't
get to Scottsdale on January 28th you
can just go to the ubu project online
and uh find ways that that you can help
yeah please go please go there's a lot
of people listening a lot of them that
deal with mental you know you know
illnesses and and and just you know I
know they're gonna love this episode
this is just an important one so thank
you JK thank you Dave and uh uh all my
love to you both thank you Michael and
all my love to both of you especially JK
and I'll see you in a couple weeks love
you my brother see you soon love you bye
guys
well not only was it a great interview
but a great cause yeah you know it's a
it's a beautiful thing I I was stunned
by that um
that statistic that um
Pro the deaths in Arizona ages 10 to 14.
the number one cause was suicide that's
terrible and uh yeah but hearing them
guys these guys talk about it and I just
think it's you know we think therapy you
know I always promote Better Health
Therapy which is amazing and exercise
and all these things and maybe seeing a
psychiatrist and getting the right meds
and all these things that you can do
but then you start doing something which
what they do this organization ubu which
is um
it's a creative thing it's it's it's
getting someone who doesn't necessarily
have to have any music background at all
and learning how to be creative and and
just writing lyrics and speaking from
their heart and writing down and
creating things that they didn't think
they could create and
um it's kind of exploded um like this
organization and uh so it's just awesome
JK and David thank you so much for
coming on the podcast and uh
yeah that's about all I have to say
about that
um it's good he's Legend music legend
what to get what'd it get great episode
coming up next week too we've got a lot
of great guests coming up this year and
I hope people continue to tune in keep
this podcast going if not I'll have to
take down all these posters and make
this into a bedroom or something it's on
a podcast room anymore but uh thanks for
all the support and a big shout out to
all my patrons
um
they really support this podcast they
without them I couldn't do it go to
patreon.com inside of you become a
patron today there's top tiers one of
the tiers is I send you packages gift
packages every couple of months and a
little note from me and there's uh q and
A's with me online we do a private
YouTube for all the patrons and there's
a bunch of stuff there so go to
patreon.com inside you I'll message you
as soon as I can thanking you and uh
yeah we really need the patrons to keep
this thing going so I I can't thank you
guys enough and without further Ado why
don't we get into the top tier patrons
Ryan
should we do that yeah let's do it let's
do it
Nancy D Leah yes Sarah little Lisa you
Kiko Jill Brian H Nico P Robert C B
correct Jason W Sophie M Kristen okay
Raj C Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy L
Jamal F Janelle B Kimberly e Mike e l
Domo 99
Santiago Chad
the bully you people you Chad W Leanne
uh P Janine R Maya P Maddie yes Belinda
and Chris
n t o Chris
H Dave H Sheila G Brad d Ray a h h
Tabitha t
good good going here Tom and Liliana a
Talia
M Betsy r d i own I own Luther Corp
that's a new one I own Luther Corp
what's up Dan uh a s n yes an angel
M Rhiannon see Cory
okay Dev Nexon Michelle
also okay hey damn Jeremy see Brandy
r d d Camille
m s s Joey I don't know M Eugene n
IA Corey Heather think famous actress
Heather yes Heather Locklear Jake
think busy be correct Megan
trainer
Megan T that's correct Mel
uh c s Orlando C Caroline r
Christine
s Eric
H Shane R Emma R Andrew M zatuichi
[Laughter]
70 70
uh seven wow Andreas
sen n Oracle Karina
and Amanda R Jen B Kevin b e e Stephanie
okay Lena
82. Billy
s Jammin
just think jamming jamming jamming
jamming jam and Jay Leanne Leon Jay
correct Luna
o r r Cindy thanks Cindy e correct Mike
e f Mike Flanagan Stone H think
Stonehenge
Brian l
Cameron
e and kdb you you got like 90 that was a
lot Jesus well a lot of them have been
here for a long time yes there's a
rhythm to it there's there's a music to
it
um
we love you we couldn't do this podcast
without you I've said it before thank
you patrons thank you everybody for
listening
um Ryan yo from the Hollywood Hills in
Hollywood California I'm Michael
Rosenberg I'm right and a little way to
the camera
we love you guys and remember please
please please be good to yourselves
that's the most important thing be good
to yourself I'll see you next week
um and even if you don't know the guess
I know you're gonna come back and visit
all right take care
[Music]